chased away by bombs and bullets these
refugees are trying to understand why
their lives were destroyed in just two
weeks the apartments shelled and burned
they took the brunt of the russian
offensive towards the capital
residents of butcher and warsaw in the
northwest of kiev were finally evacuated
after being locked up in their basements
for days with little food and water
their cities now under russian control
the russians tell us not to be afraid
they will not hurt us but they create
conditions that are very frightening we
see that people who try to move out of
the city by cars carrying their things
are being shot at we could see the front
seat covered in blood
switlana dikhtia escaped with her
husband and children after russian
troops shot at her house and took over
the apartment block
they said nothing to people whose
apartments they occupy to one person
they said just go to the basement one
neighbor wanted to come to his flat to
take some clothes before evacuating but
they did not allow him he left with only
his documents
others tell us about russian soldiers
throwing smoke grenades into basements
to force people out and ordering men and
boys to strip and crawl a woman tells us
an 11 year old boy was killed doing that
they have not only managed to escape a
war zone but also the harshness of life
on the russian occupation many here are
too afraid to share their stories on
camera instead of liberating ukrainians
from nazism as vladimir putin says he
wants to do many hearsay there is
nothing liberating about this war
the russian advance towards the capital
received a serious blow when ukrainian
forces destroyed part of a large column
of tanks the ukrainian air force so far
has also managed to protect give from
serious attacks from the sky but ukraine
is suffering losses too
our tanks were bombed as well in the
streets of butcher there is a large
column of destroyed russian tanks but
close to our house there's a column of
ukrainian tanks also destroyed
ukraine
escaped russian occupied butcher just
one hour away from kiev he says russian
soldiers smashed people's phones and
took their sim cards
i asked them guys what are you doing
here everyone here speaking russian who
are you trying to liberate
many here are from donbass we came in
2014. they gestured to me that they had
no idea
while russian soldiers might not be sure
about the goal of this war to many
ukrainians it's clear they believe
vladimir putin is aiming for maidan
square in the center of kiev a symbol of
a revolution eight years ago that
brought ukraine closer to europe a price
that ukraine will defend with all they
have step farson al jazeera keefe